エンディング
よーし、テンパった!
ギャン、ウー、スー、チーの4面待ちだが、
ハネマンではトップ目はない。
どうせ捨て牌を見れば染めているのは見え見え。
ならばここは、
リーチをかけて自分で積もるしかない。
ドラのウーアンさえ引かなければ勝てる。
一発積もれ
ロン タッピン三色 インフェコン ドラドラ
ダブロンです ショウサンゲン ドラドラ
ロン コンロー トイトイ ハーツ ドラサン
つかーん!
失礼、リーチ・ジュンチャー1発も6000ウォール。よろしくうしし。
1つ積んでは父のため。
2つ積んでは母のため。
3つ積んではオラのため。
そ、その声は!
お待ちしてました。
我々は、こういうもんです。
逃がす!
なんだい!
なんだ?
神秘にするんだい!
なんだ?あと3万しかねえだ。
ちっ!いいか?来月は少なくとも10万は稼ぐだぞ、おめえ。いいな?
さて、今日はどこ飲み行くかな?
最近できたレースクイーンパブにでも行くか?
いいんじゃない?いいんじゃない?
ごめんなさい
あなたは豊臣くんじゃない
私よ
高3の時同級生だった秋名よ
そう
1ヶ月のアルバイト代を全部
その上家具や布団まで取られちゃったのね
ひどいわ
ねえ 豊臣くん 高校の時のこと覚えてる?
あの頃のあなたは本当に輝いていた
それではこの問題を
はい 青谷ちゃん 上がり
チェ
徳川 答えてみろ
は?
FXとGXはいくつだ?
えっと
1かよ
違う
2かよ
3かよ
違う
ちかや
ちがう
どっかや
少しは考えることせんかん
まあいい
じゃあ代わりに豊臣答えてみなさい
はい
FカッコXイコールKカッコEの2X乗マイナス1
GカッコXイコール2分の1カッコEの2X乗プラス1です
うん
さすが豊臣
みんなも彼を見習うように
てれてしまうな
ああ、また豊臣くんに負けちゃったわね
今回は運が良かっただけですよ、早見さん
ううん、あなたの実力よ
ねえ豊臣くん、あなたは将来何になるつもりなの?
教師です
今の若者は生きる目的を失っている
僕は生きることの素晴らしさを教えることのできる教師になりたいんです
素敵
あの時のあなたの瞳は夢と希望に輝いていたわ
でもその輝きは降参になってからいつの間にか消えてしまった
ぼ、僕は麻雀なんかしません
お前打てんだろ
知ってるぜ
てめえ子供の時からずっと家庭麻雀してたって話じゃねえか
俺たちとは付き合えねえって言うなか
か、かんちゃん一回だけですよ
この時からあなたの人生は大きく変わってしまったわ
そうこなくっちゃな兄弟
789の3色にじゅんちゃん確定か
トン一曲でこんだて張ってしまって
いきなりおやっぱでなんてつもっちゃみんなに悪いかな
リーチだ
ドラはローソドラマタギナスチーソあたりか
おーしまったさすがにこれは切れないな
ピンク3色でもゴッパあるしここはひとまず一発を避けて
おーし追っかけリーチだ
バニーパワーピンが3枚
ピンズ待ちはなさそうだな
素直にサブローアンスチーワンあたりか
これはいけない
ローアンは2人に危ないし
バニー2枚切れていて3枚目
非常に危険だ
3色も消えるがやむを得ない
あんだつも悪いな
一発だったらいいな
華麗な回し打ち
積もりました。ピンフ、ツモ、700点オールです。
なんだ。うまく打てば、じゅんちゃん三色でねえか。
ええ。しかし、君のリーチにこのスースを止めたんだ。
バカ、違うよ。ああ、オラマンガンなのに。
カンウーアン町の初三色ドラ1。
ひっかけでもないし、ダマテンでもマンガンじゃないか。
で、でもどうせ君のリーチにこれ当たってたよね
あ、全然当たってねえよ
リーチ三眼光ドラ1
いい手なのについてねえな
なんであの手でローピン2枚切ってリーチなんだ
そっちもむちゃくちゃじゃないか
なんでじゅんちゃん三色六線オールをピン2つものみの700オールにしたんだ
リーチ
倒し倒し
たーし!一発ツモ!
え?なんで?リーチ賭けたかいと同じじゃない!
くぅー、ほんとついてねーや。リーチ一発ツモ、ピンフ、ドラドラ、ハネマンだけだ。
これ一発で高めの言いわん、一通ツモんなきゃ何にもならねーんだよなー。
ほんとだなー。
バイマン逃しやがって、調子悪いんじゃねーのー?
何を言ってるんだ、この人たちは。
よし、リーチだ。
すごい図ではいだな。
いいピンでも切っとくか。
一発!
な、なんだりゃ!
リーチ一発、ドラドラ。
さすが、開けちゃうまいな。
いや、つい迷彩を作ってしまうんだな。
プロもビビるんでねが。
マンズなら何を引いてもパイマンテンパイじゃないか!
あら?
ほら、パイが少し多いみたいだな。見てみれ、ほれ。
火の布の実の世のパイのパイのパイ時だ。
ああ、本当だ。十七杯ある。
ツグとは四枚捨てればいいだっぺ。
ターハイは上がりほうきですよ。
あれ?
何、セゴイこと言ってんだよ!
仲間の麻雀だぜ。
嘘じゃんかよ
まったくむちゃくちゃだな
ローン高めー
単品3食1ぺーこー
ずがー
あれから3年
その間に彼らは
あなたのすべてを
奪い取っていったのね
昔
今
トヨタミ君、お願い
3年前のあなたに戻って
私、私、あの頃のあなたのことが好きだったの
トヨタミ君
やっほー
おー!やっほー!
豊臣くん!あの時の豊臣くんね!
そうなのね!
豊臣くーん!
お久しぶりー!
もう麻雀はやめて
もう麻雀はやめてね
秋名の言葉が降りしきる秋雨とともに
豊臣の胸にどこまでもどこまでも染みていくのであった
どうやらあの野郎本気らしいな
どうする?
あいつが麻雀やめちまったら
俺たちの生活上がったりだぜ
心配するなって
体に染み込んだ麻雀の匂いは
そう簡単に拭いて落とせるもんでね
トヨトミ君
こ、こりゃ
一体
やあ、君たちいらっしゃい
ひるむな。乗り込むぞ。
さあ、トヨタミー。バキメスっからよ。引けよ!
僕、もう麻雀はやめたんです。
お前、そんな切ないこと言うなよ。
聞こえないのか?
お前に捨てられたパイたちの嘆きが。
え?麻雀パイの嘆き?
パイが寂しがって、おめえは呼んでるでねえか。
おめえさんの気持ちはよくわかりやした
マージャンを捨てて真っ当に生きようって決意がそこまで固いなら
もう何も言い合いしません
しかしねトヨさん
物事にはけじめってものがあるんじゃないですか
けじめ
最後に一番円切りマージャンを売っておくれ
こう言ってんですよ
円切りマージャン
最低ハンチャン10回は売ってもらいやしゅう
ええ、そんな、ハンチャン10回なんて
さあ、みんな気を入れてやんどーす
おーい
おめでおやだ、ざまみろってよ
バカめ、おらちーちゃん大とくぎだぜ
チュン
ラッキー、オート押し
ふざけろ
トン
あんた、トヨタミ。ほれ、おめえの番だぞ。
さっきから黙ってて、元気ねえなあ。
もう、麻雀はやめてね。
いや、しかしこれは縁切り麻雀。
とにかく、ハンちゃんを10回やれば、こいつらと縁が切れる。
よ、よーし、なるべく負けを抑えるおとなしい麻雀に徹しよう
選手防衛ハルネズミ麻雀
ち
あんたおめえ、第一だっから泣くなよ
出たぜ、奴の貧乏麻雀
第一だっからこんなに両面泣いてんの
ガッツ、ポン
親の第一打、チェン泣かなかったよな
ローン!情け無用の三足麻雀
賞賛本一、ちゃんと
ドラが一個あったら倍満だな
あんだそれ、一回も積もんねえで上がりかよ
ハイパイで勝ってやがる
まあ、はんちゃん10回やるうち一度はこういうアクシデントもあるだろう
偶然それが初っ端に出ただけだ
よし、この手は物にしよう
スチーソーは危ないから先に切っておこう
よし、ギャンワン一発ツモでメンタンピン一発ツモ三食
バイバン取り返せる
リッチ
あんだあんだおらトン誰かなっけ
トンポンだな一発消しとこ
それじゃんわん
おし
いいわんかちょっと待ってカンだな
と、とおし
リンシャンからこれ引いてきちゃったん
よかったースチーソーはほとんど純からだもんね
何考えてんだ早く切れよリーチかけてんだろお前
親っぱね振り込むよりスーソーかんして
ノーテンリーチのバップを払おう
カン!
ギィ!
ま、またイーワンがドラに…
アア!
しまった。シャボで受ければよかった。
ポン!
ということは、明智は嘘の短気待ち…
引くなよ
パイが泣いてる
これはまさか
おい何やってるだ早く積もれよ
俺たちここ二巡ばっかしパイに触ってねえんだぞ
早くしろよな
分かった
勝つかよ、こんなの
ダブトン、ドラガー、11と数え役マンだな
10発が
なるほど、なるほど
そう、そういうわけか。そろそろ俺の番だな。行くぞ!
何考えてんだ、一体!
ビーチ!
ギョザ食ったな、ったく。
ほら、ペ!
投資!
現物、投資!
慎太郎、兵をこかなきゃいい奴なんだけどな。
しゃ!通し!
通し!通し!通し!
一発、積もれ!
積もった!
リーチ一発積もったんやおう、ドライオン!
そんな、ぼかな!
死ぬなぁ
もう、マージャンはやめてね
嘘だ、このままではマージャンがやめられなくなってしまう
俺はこのまま負けてしまうわけじゃいかないんだ!
あ、ロビン切った?
え?
え?いや、間違い!
あ、ちょっとしたミス!
本当はこれ…
あ、パーピン出るか?
ち、ち、ちがった!隣のパイ来ちゃった!ごめんごめん!
あの、本当の、本当はこれ…
通った?
出た!ドタカメ!
やっと出したか、このバカだらけ!
ん トリプルロンありだったなぁ俺はピンク3色ドレイジー
俺ねほんちゅん3アンコウ アネマン
俺 薬マン
ん
じゃあまあそういうことで
それ預かっておくぜ また近いうちに食っからよ縁を切るはずの麻雀がますます
縁を深めることになっちまっただなあ 皮肉が凝った
アキナちゃんとの約束を破り
再び麻雀地獄へと落ちていくトヨトミ
果たして彼に明るい未来はやってくるのだろうか
ズッガーン
トヨトミ君たらあんなに言ったのにどうしようもないんだから
知らない
次回スーパーズガンは
ハッピーバースデーズガンとフラレテズガンの2本です
きっと見てね
眠っちゃいや
ご視聴ありがとうございました
バネバナナズルド
リジーとピンクリッツ
シボチカミチャマジャン仲間
勝負かけたら情け無用の狙い撃ち
君にはアゲマント素敵じゃないか
僕とワンガンズボローよ
掴んだ幸せ掴もうぞ
スーパースタート
嫌いでヤクワン巻くところ
飛んでいかないんだ
ハートイン
ハートフォーメント
ここは 三面町どころ
行く ぶかんきゃむ
腹 traditionally
おщstringsколkoso
坂町
頬
言こ
僅か
横
感
bring
マイ
スカ
スカルトン スカルトン ガキカメット ガタン ガンナイロ